البحر الابيض المتوسط قبله المهاجرين غير
الشرعيين ومقبره الكثير منهم
بهذه الامواج تصطدم احلام كثير من هؤلاء
البسطاء الذين فروا من اوطانهم قاصدين
المجهول
فرار يغلفه الامل بالنجاه من اوضاعهم
المعيشيه البائسه لكن في جنباته يكمن خطر
الموت غرقا في هذا البحر الواسع
في السنوات الاخيره سجلت مئات حوادث الغرق
المميته التي خلفت الاف القتلى والمفقودين
وخلال اقل من عشر سنوات ما بين عامي 2014
لقي اكثر من 26 الف مهاجر مصرعهم او فقدوا
اثناء عبورهم البحر المتوسط الذي تحولت
مياهه من ممر بحري لعبور البشر والسفن
لاكثر طرق الهجره فتكا في العالم
اننا نشهد زياده حاده في عدد الاشخاص
اليائسين الذين يعرضون حياتهم لخطر جسيم
لا يمكننا ان نتحمل التردد او ننخرط في
نقاش اخر حول من هو المسؤول فحياه البشر
على المحن
في ايطاليا بالتحديد خفر السواحل الايطالي
انقذ حوالي الف شخص في ثلاثه ايام فقط ففي
الاشهر الماضيه من العام الحالي وصل الى
الشواطئ الايطاليه اكثر من 30 الف مهاجر
وهو رقم اكبر بكثير من رقم عام 2022 الذي
وصل فيه نحو
7900 شخص
هؤلاء فروا من سوداويه الحياه في بلادهم
اغلبهم من دول تعاني من الفقر والازمات
كساحل العاج وغينيا وبنغلاديش وباكستان
وغيرها ونقطه انطلاقهم الرئيسيه كانت تونس
املين في الحصول على حياه ربما ليست كهذا
الليل الدامس ظلامه على شواطئ الاسود
قوات خفر السواحل التونسيه انتشرت جثث 15
شخصا كانوا يحصرون تحت القارب بالقرب من
ساحل صفاقس وقبل ذلك انتشرت 10 جثث اخرى
وانقذت 72 مهاجرا من القارب الغارق
قضيه الهجره غير الشرعيه لاوروبا تؤرق
حكومات بعض الدول هناك فدول كانت اكثر
صرامه مع هؤلاء
المهاجرينمارك وهولندا والنمسا سنتي
القوانين وشددت العقوبات بسبب زياده
اعدادهم كما زادت خطابات الكراهيه نحو
المهاجرين تلك الدول ظنت ان نهجها الاكثر
صرامه سيحد من تدفق المهاجرين لكن الحقيقه
على ارض الواقع عكس ذلك ومن يغامر بحياته
هربا من واقعه المزري لا يابه لها كذا
عقوبات والمحصله نراها امامنا معاناه
بشريه لا تتوقف في عرض بحر اصبح ينضح
بالجثه البشريه